c'est quoi Berkeley has a high ankle
sprain he's expected to miss four to
eight weeks Chris Mortensen of ESPN
reports that Berkeley is getting a
second opinion from noted Foot and Ankle
guy Robert Anderson in Charlotte on
Wednesday Barclays already met with
Giants team consultant dr. Martin
O'Malley after suffering that high ankle
sprain the expectation is Berkeley will
miss up to two months but he once came
back after only two weeks with a high
ankle sprain during his freshman year at
Penn State and Chris this is weird
and maybe it's the daniel Jones frenzy
in New York but this is a big injury
this is a big deal and nobody seems to
be losing their minds about it the way
they should be no I I think you're
you're spot-on Mike they're not up here
in New York for a superstar player I
mean say qualm Barkley is one of the
best offensive players in the game but I
do think you know your take that yes
it's it's the daniel Jones frenzy is so
real up here with New York right now I
do think that's taken off some of the
edge about say Quon being hurt and a few
of my giant friends too you know I've
just heard heaver even here in the NBC
office like they don't care right now
it's almost like they're looking at it
like I'll save sake one next year's the
year we need them it's almost about all
about the development of Daniel Jones
right now and that's kind of the sense I
get here that's why there's not like a
panic or a media frenzy about say Quan
Barkley being hurt yeah I agree there's
that relief that they now have something
to build around in the future even
though this year kind of conceded it to
the Cowboys and I think if you're in
that division at this point it's
tempting to say it's Dallas's year let
them have it let's regroup and rebuild
for next year but when you look at that
division now with Daniel Jones
if Dwayne Haskins ends up being the real
Washington carson wentz in philly dak in
dallas this is the new NFC South
potentially for great quarterbacks top
to bottom it really is it's impressive
young guys who were you know the future
its I mean dak Prescott the dollars just
keep going up on a weekly basis I mean I
watch that film yesterday against the
Dolphins and man that he makes some
unreal play
throws once again and we know whence and
what he's capable of and yeah daniel
Jones certainly off to a good start
which could set up to you know great
years of rivalries we are looking for
that next you know great quarterback
rivalry and and more Peyton Manning
verse Tom Brady type of things and at
least has some possibilities there in
the NFC's but hey Daniel Jones say Quan
Barkley in the future is gonna be
special I feel pretty good about that
just saying that now what I've seen I
mean between Pat schirmer's offense and
how he can get the running back the ball
and wait Daniel Jones looks through the
preseason and last week if you're a
giant fan you got to be excited about
that combination going forward yeah and
and if I'm the Giants what do I really
do do I risk reactivation do I risk
something more serious is gonna linger
into preparations for 2020 how do you
balance that out I think you just want
the guy back if you can get him back in
and that's the best news for the Giants
yeah
Daniel Jones did what he did on Sunday
without say Quan Barkley right you add
say Quan Barkley to the mix you know I'm
talking about the comeback Barkley was
there early on and they did the read
option play and it helps set it up
because Barkley was the guy that
everybody thought had the ball right but
the twenty eight to ten deficit was
overcome with Barkley in a walking boom
right and and and so you think I'm think
about where they could go from here as
they build out this team so I think
there's there's reason for optimism
reason for hope
regardless of whether or not so I say
come on Barkley comes back at all this
year yeah definitely and to your point
that's gonna be the exciting thing about
what the Giants could be offensively cuz
Pat Shermer you know as we saw in the
game yesterday he's got a lot of good
ways and creative ways to push the ball
down the field and Daniel Jones is
aggressive he's looking to stand in the
pocket and make throws down the field
and why that's important is because as
they continue to do that
defenses are gonna be more aware of it
they're gonna push people back in the
secondary to take away some of those big
plays and that's where say Kyle Barkley
will become special in the pass game and
that's where they're gonna be able to
stress people when he is healthy because
oh you want to you want to drop back and
take away our deep shots down the field
oh well man there's a lot of room under
your sake while Berkeley one-on-one with
your linebacker let's see how you do
there you know a little bit you know
Drew Brees Alden chimera ish I mean I
think sake what Berkeley can be used in
a very similar way yet he's probably a
you know he is he's a better between the
tackles runner than Alvin Kamara you
know we talked earlier about Super Bowl
odds and the Giants are at 200 to 1 now
to win it all and I don't think that's a
longshot that anyone who is inclined to
wager their hard-earned money should
consider but they could get to 2 & 3
this weekend with a win over Washington
then the Vikings are coming to town the
following week who knows what'll happen
there after New England Patriots
probably isn't going to be a game that
works out well for the Giants but hey
the Giants historically
have given the Patriots everything they
can handle yeah although with different
quarterbacks different coaches different
everything Cardinals game should be a
win at the Lions very fascinating
Cowboys game at MetLife Stadium may you
know I I mean I'm I'm not ready to just
say they're done yeah I gotta say let's
close the books on 2019 they could make
it interesting even though they should
be owin 3 they should have lost that
game to Tampa Bay ultimately it was what
Tampa Bay did wrong that delivered the
victory for the Giants not what the
Giants did right but I just like the
fact that with so many teams that are
truly hopeless here's a team that has
some hope yeah right at least and into
October right cuz it cuz my concern
about this season the NFL's 100 seasons
they want to be very special they want
as many teams to be alive in December as
possible yeah I think by Thanksgiving it
really is gonna be whittled down to 10
teams who have a realistic shot at most
yeah I'd get into the Super Bowl to the
regular season but it'll look great in
the playoffs we'll have fun that way
exactly yeah
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports